[Music]
three
two one action hey guys welcome back to
off the record when we talk about
whatever
we want we got cancer whatever we want
welcome thank you so much i've known you
for like a decade
but i finally meet you i've known about
you guys
for nearly a decade and so nice of
finally why didn't we ever work together
then
uh well i have prejudices and uh
towards certain cultures and i'm working
through them and i think i'm
i'm a better man now which culture do
you have the most prejudice he can't be
asian because he worked with tim
chinese yeah i'm a japanese i hate the
japanese oh these japanese
i mean the koreans the koreans oh he's
korean half korean korean you're half
korean
you feel angry inside is that what we
are i have a lot of anger myself
and you are korean then the stereotype
is they are the fiery
so i'm glad we could finally uh after 10
years well we never
even reached out either but we have
mutual friends
yeah we have i don't like to see it that
way okay i just like to see it
his way and it's his back well me and
cass go way back and we worked together
and we never reached out how come you
never brought him on the show how come
you never
me and steve are trying to because i
there's this whole snafu where i
uh apparently didn't accept his wedding
invitation or i forgot about it and
we're
at least you got one rehabilitating our
relationship we're trying to get it
figured we'll get it sorted
i didn't even get invited coming your
way yeah at least you got invited
i just have to order it nice and send it
well we didn't even know steve back then
no we did yes we did he didn't invite us
we weren't invited we were new friends
we were
we're new we knew we were new friends
but my family
was supposed to come and they all
snubbed my [ __ ] wedding anyway so i
should have just invited you guys
because
i didn't know that i had more space than
i had than i did but what were we doing
were we even in the states we were not
going to go
you guys were wrong gio probably
wouldn't have gone nope i don't think we
knew you back then
yeah we did we met him in person yes yes
he was on here that's [ __ ] up steve
that's what i'm saying
he was just a new friend at the time he
didn't feel loyal
but anyway i'm so happy i'm glad i could
bring all that up and uh
by the way the wedding thing is not a
big deal are you sure that's not what he
told us dude no it really isn't
nikki not it was
how bad you felt it's really nice let me
help you understand nikki for a sec she
doesn't put
enough zip on her sarcasm sometimes and
so she just demolishes people without
knowing that she
she was joke she's like i was joking for
a real joke and she finds out later that
she wrecked somebody yeah there you go
that's why nikki's awesome thank you for
making her clear
you're most welcome because she told me
about the situation and how you very
kindly reached out and were like
yo i i didn't realize and i was like oh
my god we don't feel that way at all
just so you know i was dming your wife
oh you were sliding in there i slid in
to say sorry
about not showing up to your wedding did
you slide out though are you still there
yeah i know i
think i'm in there still yeah how do you
slide out do you just delete it you
don't slide out you stay
no you can put like a peace sign you
can't pull you can't pull out of there
or that emoji where he's opening the
door
like you're leaving i had some girl sent
me a message because she found out i was
single online because i've been
broadcasting that because i'm lonely
yeah and
she said looking for you she's in greece
and she found uh she found me and she
sent me a message
and sometimes it's like oh cool like
thank you for the nice
flattery and like oh she's like i'd love
to take you to dinner i'm like ah you
know like
you're in greece and like it's covid and
then she sent another one like oh man i
really wish
and then i just stopped replying and
then i
looked back in the text and it was all
deleted like she had removed
herself you i didn't know you could
delete it
you can unsend on instagram yes why
because she was ashamed
it was embarrassing she slid out of your
dms that's a slide out that's why i
bring it up that's a full slide out
that's true that's embarrassing and if
she's out there that made me want her
more
of course it did what kind of games are
you playing
are you going that's like he's single
dude greek tricks are hot though yeah
i've got
my uh my compass is cracked and my
picker's
jacked yeah put that on her shirt nice i
heard you are looking for a uterus
though that's true
a warm yeah so i would love to just be a
single dad we've gone over this on big
mood girls but being
you know being a dad with a baby bjorn
and just like at walt disney world at a
tractor
a slaying [ __ ] slip just bringing it
all home so you want to just adopt a kid
then that you can you can attract
women i don't want somebody else's kid
on me yeah i get it so you want to
impregnate a woman
keep the kid but separate with her and
then attract other women i will learn to
love
this child but not right away at first
it is a tool
to attract why not perhaps get love uh
the puppy is uh i can't he's not a
service dog i can't bring him into walt
disney true
well you could get a little service vest
for the puppy yeah that'll be really
good every dog is a service dog now
yeah i heard what about that picking up
chicks at the dog park with their dog
you know that's a great tip
and i've done i've done that in the past
and it's a great icebreaker but he's too
big now it doesn't really
but when your dog bites their dog it's
like a you know yeah he like my dog gets
very that's a bummer it's representative
of the owner
that's what they say so that means
you're dodging bullets then
thanks for your bullets dodge single
cast you ever
give her you're talking about chick from
the dog park whatever and then you
realize that you've only been talking
about your dogs and you go on several
dates and you've only talked about your
animals
that's happened
yeah that's it one one's a trumper the
other one's a biden and they just can't
figure it out
can't not talk about politics i didn't
mean to worry
i don't even know who those people are
yeah
all i know is that i'm getting emails
and texts every few minutes about who i
who i voted for
yeah and they want more money they're
using your i do i donate and then
they'll send me an email that night
saying they want more there's like no
there's no appreciation text that's like
hey good
nice thank you yeah it's always about
like we need more who got our numbers
are you guys getting like texts and [ __ ]
from like biting camping
was getting tech texting me i get i get
texts from uh michelle
obama's campaign thingy mobber yeah wait
michelle obama michelle obama has her
own
she's she's not campaigning for office
but she has her own like
i don't know like group that she's
trying to push their agenda whatever it
is and i always get
emails from she's stumping for biden
that's that's kind of the whole jam
right now
stumped them for vitals stumping they
call it stumping like stump speech
you go and give a speech that's
basically the same speech in a bunch of
different places bought your dinner for
the homie yeah
oh i see i don't even know how she got
my email
that's what i did you probably signed up
on some list years ago like i did and
then i get
i get all kinds of these emails i get i
get trumpets pence emails i get biting
emails i get bernie emails and i get the
uh
joe i get joe jorgensen and i didn't
even sign up for any of those things i
signed up for the jean-claude vadam when
i don't get emails i've been getting a
lot of medicaid
emails where i'm like i'm not senior
like
why you should go get checked though
just to see trans vaginal mesh
yeah probably yeah you could have an
older [ __ ]
that's true i don't get dick pill emails
anymore good for you man
you just do you really fix that problem
because they you stop searching for them
yeah but anyway anyways yeah yeah dude
you're a gamer
love to game do you but why don't you
stream the games too well you know
that's not a that's not a terrible idea
um but part of part of what i like about
gaming is just it's just for me
i feel that you don't have a gaming
channel you just
i have a twitch channel um and i did you
know i did a live show for a while and
then i would play on twitch
after i play rocket league but um i get
most of it
i love it i don't just play rocket
league i compete oh [ __ ]
yeah he's a known legend wait do you
mess with the with the
settings though so you can always be
boosting the entire time
that's me and isaac's favorite oh you
play rocky league two oh that sounds
like cheating
i know it's i don't need your handle to
report so [ __ ] fun
yeah i i would love to stream you know
and i think uh
but it would have to be you know it's
like when porn stars
when they come home they want to have
sex they've been having sex all day you
know so
you've got to be able to have it make it
feel special that's true
so it's a different kind of sex that's a
different kind of sex you know it's like
a
love me missionary looking in the eyes
sex is at home
and then at work it's um you're getting
many dicks on the face
yeah yeah yeah one of these things yeah
yeah yeah probably one of those
situations
and that's not necessarily how i would
do it at home no i'm saying yeah
you're much more of a gentleman i don't
take that many at home
are you he's not doing this at home not
skiing
are you a gaming and podcast type of guy
where you will play the game and listen
to something this was one of those
chairs where i could do this
you could relax and talk to yourself wow
like talk
like what's what's that like people that
just talk and then they just play games
listening to pogba it's a phenomenon
that i've stumbled upon where people now
game and they also listen to podcasts
it's like a whole thing i do do the
audience hear it too no they like mute
the
in-game sounds and then they listen to a
podcast so you don't hear a 10 year old
uh calling you racial slurs no oh
i do that with rocket league because
it's totally different muscle
you know yeah can you pay attention if
you're listening to another podcast
yeah how do you think i'm listening to
alex jones i gotta be able to
all the time that i'm putting in is got
you know i got to be doing something
with my hands and then i can actually
listen pretty well
that's what i do when i play animal
crossing i listen to my audiobooks
great way yeah cause then nobody can
just slam you for just playing too many
games you're actually learning or
reading i'm being productive
i don't even know how i'm gonna segue
this but today's video is brought to you
by
amazon alexa baby that was a perfect
segment it was a perfect segway
and amazon alexa is super cool
especially if you're at home and for me
i like to use it
when i'm cooking because i always need
to know the timer when i'm searing a
steak or if i put something in the oven
just to double check it
so you can always just say hey alexa
three minute timer and they'll put in
that timer
and what's super cool now is that
through amazon alexa you can turn your
home into a smart home
i'm always looking for ways to make my
life easier and we're all juggling too
much so the ability to offload even the
smallest tasks
can make a difference one convenience
that i can't believe
i live without smart bulbs connected to
alexa and right now
amazon alexa is offering a special smart
lighting bundle
for our listeners with an amazon smart
lighting bundle you can turn your home
into a smart home in just
minutes setup is easy and you don't need
any extra equipment
just connect your smart bulb to the echo
dot and you're all set set every
possible mood with over 16 million
light colors to choose from or control
the lights in your home with the sound
of your voice just say alexa
turn on the lights you can also set
lighting routines to gently wake you up
in the morning which can be very
peaceful
help you wind down at night or
completely turn off
at a certain time right now you can get
20 off your amazon smart lighting bundle
only at amazon.com off the record
every bundle includes an echo dot smart
speaker
and a scene glide okay
a speaker in a scene-glide
color-changing light bulb that's
20 off at amazon.com off the record
that wasn't single it might be sing led
no it's
seeing glen yeah that's that's how they
say pronounce it like
oh interesting i know i was confused too
but i know how to read
good job dude good for you bro but uh so
isaac finally downloaded rust oh did he
yeah oh good
that's an old game yeah so but fun do
you
play that one nope no no but i do
understand that it's a survival game and
you can kind of just meet random dudes
i've seen a lot of what so i use it to
meet randomly
kind of like random naked dudes honestly
too my understanding is like fortnight
with
minecraft kinda with penises yeah really
with nudity
yeah so you start off completely naked
and you're shivering or whatever
and then you have to like find uh
materials build
a fort for yourself build like a shelter
for yourself a real survival game yeah
but then the entire game just becomes
about raiding other people and ruining
their time
because you realize that your shelter
isn't that great and somebody's been
playing this game longer than you has a
better shelter
and all you need is a rock or a stick
and you can essentially go ambush
somebody with a nicer shelter do they
have weapons
oh yeah they have bad weapons they have
sentry guns bro and you're like how the
[ __ ] did you even build this [ __ ]
i have barely even four walls around my
head wow
it's crazy so over time you can like
evolve and like
it's kind of like age of empires and
stuff well it's a
it's like a shooter game almost but but
yeah so like you become a caveman to
to the stages of like aj pairs yeah
exactly that's tight it's pretty tight
that's a pretty good idea
well it's actually you don't feel that
way when you have a little axe and then
somebody has an ak-47 oh
you just don't feel that way do you ever
get close or is it always i know there's
like a feature where you can make it
either blurry or add underwear but like
do you ever get close
you do get close just walk around with a
dangling
when you start a character in this game
you are permanently assigned to this it
randomly selects a race and a gender
race and gender
like isaac's an asian woman and casey is
a black guy
that's tight see i'm a black guy too but
i'm not a black guy with a huge penis
like many of you racists would think
right i am a black guy with very average
sized penis i think to even maybe small
penis is the eight does the asian girl
have big tits
uh they're like a decent size they
wobble pretty nice when they run
uh i don't know that's an important
question no let him answer uh
i would say probably yes i don't know
because isaac
he does isaac turn around and have her
run toward him all the time well
no he ends up like zooming out you can
see his own avatar
but i told him though that he could just
have it unblurred and just be like here
go ahead and
enjoy or not enjoy it not enjoy but like
just be
um desensitized to the human body
because everyone has these bodies
don't sexualize it and you're okay but
he still ended up deciding wearing the
underwear says you showing off your
shoulders like like a harlot
do you have to level up um according to
the game
or can you like do you have to go
clothing
food shelter or can you just be always
the naked person with the ak-47 you can
always be the naked person
that's cool but you have to go build the
ak-47 which is hard
okay but here's the here's the greatest
part of the game if you don't like the
race that you got assigned
too bad you can't [ __ ] change it
right so that's what's beautiful about
it is like
you started off as this person and
you're just gonna have to figure it out
you're gonna have to let you have to
learn to love it and i kind of like that
is the asian girl also realistic where
she's a gold digger and she can
uh [ __ ] you for your shelter oh yeah
interesting what's that based on
uh just based on what i've been reading
here and there mm-hmm personal
experience it was actually a mexican
girl that did it to me oh
she's sitting next to you maybe are you
talking [ __ ] are there mexicans in the
game
no oh then that's [ __ ] up that's not
realistic at all
it's not realistic i think he will solve
racism half of the world is mexican
what the [ __ ] or wow i think that's
accurate latin yeah half the world's
latin
i don't like it yeah really half right i
mean that's all of south america
half of the united states you're just
going half of the united states yeah
kirby you're an equatorist
yeah you spain you got spain too how
great would it be if every single game
just picked your your [ __ ] for you race
and gender wise and then you had to
nope [ __ ] that why i want to choose a
hot girl
cause then when you play as a hot girl
guys actually think you're a girl and
they give you all these gifts
oh i thought you're gonna say you could
always stare at some nice titties that
too
like you want to stare at a buff man
that or i mean like tomb raider it was
awesome right it was great right wait
which game tomb raider
oh yeah like why would you want to was
it oh absolutely
dude like when you can choose a girl
character
when you go into the world guys just
give you all this like free upgrades and
[ __ ] all the time
you put on a woman's voice too no i
don't talk to him i'm just like chilling
and guys will come up
welcome to being a woman that's
literally what happens
that's perfect that's what tomb raider
made me look super into triangle-sized
tits
absolutely before it was like lara croft
it was madonna
and that was it like this way this way
this way no they're like pointed out
like that
my grandma had the water cooler cup the
polygon yeah they actually made
because the first two minute games she
had triangle tits and that was enough
for us
yeah that was and now you have games
like cyberpunk
2077 coming out where there's full-on
nudity in the game and you'll be able to
yeah look at it and you'll be able to
decide how
uh how big your breasts or your penis
oh so it doesn't it won't solve racism
or sexism i'll at least have a chick
with super huge tits though
yeah you get a lap dance on gta i mean
it's pretty cool
that's great yeah and you know in gta
there's a stat you can go in the
settings and see how many hours
so if you want to prank your buds a good
prank is to go and look at their stats
and see how many hours they've spent in
the strip club do can you imagine
oh yeah because when you're in there
it's kind of boring yeah can you imagine
actually sitting there for hours on end
i've done it just to i might have like i
mean
look okay are you safe here well you
know because there's different camera
angles
and sometimes you want to see from here
and then you can touch them and then
they respond
yeah different chicks too and then the
music's good yeah
sometimes give me something what does it
sound like it's good oh you know
it's like uh you know
safe yeah foreign all the good stuff a
lot of classes yup
nice it looks like you could pick them
up and go uh
they'll start living with you and stuff
too wait the strippers will yeah they'll
become your girlfriends
yeah you can save them yeah from their
lives
they show up to your apartment do they
fall in love with you too no i just
think like you get their personal number
and then you go on dates with them or
whatever like they come to your house
i might be thinking about real life i
don't know if this is gta you're getting
confused again yeah i think that was an
earlier
i played 48 hours straight of gta and i
went to 7-eleven to go get some stuff
and i was like man
this feels like the game yeah like i
should i should shoot this guy for
the snickers bars like i just just drive
right into the [ __ ] it doesn't help
that we live in la
and all of the things just look this
just like the [ __ ] game yeah cause
they build it off of it right
yeah dude yeah what was the la one sen
something it's the reason
yeah yeah well they're both yeah even
the
gta 5 is based on like uh pretty perfect
too
it's pretty la yeah like they have
griffith park the observatory they have
all the landmarks they have santa monica
pier is the water green there too it's
really close smog smog even like big
bear it looks like
like arrowhead big bear out there the
desert
inside and if you play the online
version of the game if you kill a guy
who's the cash register guy yeah you get
500 bucks but
if you play the online game you know
that ain't [ __ ] it's a good lesson it's
not even worth your time to kill the
[Music]
dude
[Applause]
[Music]
you